thank you good afternoon I'm delighted
to be determinist auric week morning for
mr. Boston I spent both nights we were
vividly reminded reminded of the painful
separation was caused by the wall we saw
a guard towers bunkers remains of the
very structure President Reagan calls
the scar of a wall it was a bit of a
walk down memory lane for me or memory
memory Strasse you could say I saw you
could say I saw a piece of history that
I was a tiny little part of back in the
late 1980s there was a plaque honoring
American troops who protected peace and
freedom in Western Europe I was proud to
play that small role I think it's
indicative of the incredible important
relationship between our two countries
over decades and decades and decades and
decades as we move forward together as
well as you said I caught a little while
I'll continue my visit here in Leipzig
we'll visit st. Nicholas Church a sacred
birthplace of German freedom and I'll
talk with some of the brave
demonstrators who thirty years ago
helped bring down the wall that divided
people will then have a chance to visit
the Halle synagogue the site of the
vicious anti sight emic Semitic attack
just last month on Yom Kippur a
sickening reminder of how there remains
much work to be done and the vigils in
the fight for religious freedom remains
an imperative for each of our two
countries you know the events of 1989
remind me of what binds us our two
countries free societies transatlantic
allies and friends we share a strong
belief in the rule of law and the
democracy human dignity free speech
freedom of religion and so many other
unalienable rights things we know to be
central these values link us together as
people in this nations and they define
our policy our foreign policy choices
not all nations share these liberal
values I spoke last week in New York
City about the nature of house Chinese
Communist Party China's governing entity
refused the world and we should speak
frankly about such things
I know Germany too is facing its
decision about how to handle its
telecommunications network this isn't
just a simple decision it's complicated
but it comes in the face of the
challenges that are presented by the
Chinese Communist Party Eiko and I spent
a fair amount of time this morning as he
said talking about Syria the United
States will continue to monitor the
ceasefire and hold human rights
violators they're accountable we're
investigating allegations of war crimes
and will continue to deliver on our
humanitarian mission there and we'll
keep urging Russia and Turkey and the
regime its allies not to take steps that
would further destabilize that already
difficult region that has caused the
mass displacement and refugee flows that
we have already seen I know to the
Germany prides itself on being an
important and valuable multilateral
partner and I express my deep
appreciation for Germany's commitment to
multilateral efforts that are in both
our interests
as well as in Europe's interests Germany
has been a great partner in supporting
our efforts to attempt to denuclearize
North Korea you've maintained pressure
on Russia to meet its commitments to
implement the Minsk agreements you stood
alongside the United States and many
European partners trying to achieve
democracy in Venezuela and in September
you stood along with France in the
United Kingdom in ascribing
responsibility for the Iran attacks or
for the attacks by Iran on Saudi oil
facilities each of these issues as at
its core the mission of protecting
unalienable rights and human dignity
something the Communists of East Germany
failed to do for so many years I look
forward to working with you echo to
protect our shared values there's no
better way to do that than to be here to
remember the victory of 1989 echo thank
you for hosting me on this very
memorable visit I will certainly never
forget it thank you
that's wonderful mr. secretary you
mentioned the events in northern Syria
the French president in an interview
that he gave declared that major was
brain dead and the trans-lux strongly
rejected that statement do you do that
too and a question addressed to the
secretary mr. come here and get the
second question so you know I think you
asked that in the right context there we
were in this place where nations of
democratic values worked so closely
together for a long time to achieve what
happened in 1989 then again in 1990
remarkable work that created freedom and
brought millions of people out of very
very difficult situations
I think NATO remains an important
critical perhaps historically one of the
most critical strategic partnerships in
all of recorded history that's why it's
frankly it's why when you hear president
for him talk about the fact that we need
to make sure that every nation shares
that burden that every nation works
alongside it's why I welcome the
comments from akk who said we're
prepared to do this by 2031 to get to
the whales committed by 2031 where I'm
happy to hear that it's it's that
relationship it is that NATO alliance
that is so central so important that's
why it is an absolute imperative of
every country participate and join in
and contribute appropriately to
achieving that shared security mission
no I do not believe that NATO is
brain-dead however fest and the
Internet's analysis my cooperation also
and above all because we are
increasingly facing challenges of a
global character and NATO is the
Alliance in which we cooperate on
security policy issues our core issue
interest is to in guarantee our security
interests in Europe and NATO does just
that and this is why we are grateful to
our American partners for their
contribution to Germany's and Europe's
security together we have to make sure
that the Alliance continues to cooperate
in the face of a number of difficult
tests we've been put to the telogen
should not be downplayed in their
importance those that we are facing but
we have an interest in the unity of
nature and its ability to take action we
should all have that very interest
suffered a setback with what happened in
Washington and use of the Ukraine trump
administration's actions this this year
and mr. Pompeo secretary Pompeo you have
said that ambassador mckinley
did not make known to you his objections
over the recalling of ambassador obama
vich but he has testified that three
times he directly appealed to you to
make a statement in her support you did
not why not do I go
we believe that there is a very positive
momentum in Ukraine right now which
began with the election of President
Solinsky and this is why we intend to
support president Solinsky in his
endeavors he has two priorities the
first of which is fighting corruption
over the past few years Germany has
already supported the Ukraine with 1.5
billion euros and we will continue to
support projects in Ukraine that are
being set in motion as part of the
reform agenda his second priority is to
achieve peace in Donbass and here - well
thanks for bearing with us we wanted to
take that to that press conference there
from Berlin with the US Secretary of
State might compare in his German
counterpart because we wanted to hear
Mike compares reaction to the several
things
French president Emmanuel macron has
described the NATO alliance as
brain-dead due to a lack of US
leadership the Secretary of State
addressed that just a few moments ago
and earlier in the day Mike Pompeo had
been tweeting about Iran saying that
Iran's plans to increase its nuclear
activity raised concerns that its
position itself for a rapid nuclear
breakout is now time he said for all
nations to reject its nuclear extortion
of increased pressure as yet this press
conference hasn't touched on Iran let's
get some reaction to what we've just
heard now of some analysis rather from
our zeroes Alan Fisher who's been
listening in in Washington what do you
make of it Alan actually if you know
I'll be interested to hear what my
pompiers got to say about the question
on Ukraine because he's been directly
asked why he may have misled
okay the American Veterinary cause isn't
it someone said well what happened in
Washington this year was that we
provided 250 million dollars worth of
security assistance defense assistance
and a hundred and forty million dollars
or so of additional security assistance
just like happened in fiscal year 18 and
fiscal year 17 and the United States
efforts to continue to fight corruption
continued throughout this year so that's
what happened in Washington with respect
to Ukraine this year and I think that's
important because
in Europe a place that understands
deeply the challenges of corruption in
Ukraine who talks about those risks to
Europe incessantly and properly and
importantly in our administration - in
the United States has been very worried
about Ukrainian corruption it's been
something that's been at the center of
the State Department's mission set and
something that we worked last year and
we will work again in the year ahead
trying to make sure that president
Olinsky has the opportunity to root out
corruption inside of his own country and
as for ambassador mckinley I clearly
follow this a lot less than you do I
haven't had to chant that it's pretty
busy world out there I've had a chance
to follow this but with respect to
ambassador mckinley i think i think he
said at the opening statement that he
put out that he wasn't particularly
involved in the ukraine file so it's not
surprising that when ambassador
Jovanovic returned to the united states
that he didn't raise that issue with me
that's it shouldn't shouldn't surprise
anyone that in May when that took place
he didn't say a thing to me okay let's
go back to what Alan Fisher in
Washington that was the answer you were
waiting for Alan what did you make of
that well that's going to be interesting
because that links into impeachment any
time a senior official in the US
administration has asked about Ukraine
you know that the underlying question is
what about impeachment and certainly the
question there was the Donald Trump said
at one point in his defense with Ukraine
he was holding back money because others
weren't doing their share and the German
Foreign Minister is saying look we put
in 1.5 billion euros so we were the
question about the ambassador of the
ambassador in evidence said that three
times it said to Mike Pompeo you need to
put out a statement supporting the
ambassador that was being recalled by
Donald Trump at the behest of Rudy
Giuliani and others and Mike Pompeo
saying there that it was never raised so
that's very interesting to go back to
the original question that you asked
about Iran certainly Mike Pompeo thinks
that is a window of opportunity here we
know that they pulled out of the Iran
nuclear deal because they wanted to
force Iran back to the table to restart
negotiations something the Iranians have
always been really opposed to and
certainly something that the European
allies have said that they are not
interested in doing at the moment
because they see around very much in
compliance with what was agreed however
there is some concern among European
allies that Iran is stepping up its
nuclear activity and so Mike Pompeo sees
a very small window of opportunity here
where he can perhaps push some of the
waverers in Europe to back their
campaign of maximum pressure to try and
force Iran back to the negotiating table
he already believes that there is
certainly pressure on the banking and
oil sector we know about the sanctions
that have been imposed by the US this is
know about a diplomatic push so he is
saying look there is a window of
opportunity here and that is why he is
making the statements he's making
particularly in Europe to Europe to try
and get them to alter their position on
Iran and add even more pressure onto the
government in Tehran all right we'll
stay listening to that press conference
in Berlin we'll bring you anything
newsworthy that comes out of it al
Jazeera's Alan Fisher reporting live
from Washington Island many thanks
indeed